it's great to welcome to the program
today Tom wheeler who is the former
chairman of the FCC the Federal
Communications Commission thanks so much
for talking to me today David great to
be with you so I mean to begin with I
think if we want to have a conversation
about what regulation of tech companies
should look like it's important to
understand how we sort of got to where
we are so maybe to start with how have
tech companies relatively successfully
avoided the type of regulation that some
believe should be in place well you know
David it's interesting I I have a new
book out called from Guttenberg to
Google the history of our future and one
of the things that it talks about is how
every time a new technology comes along
it's the innovators that make the rules
and and that's the situation that we're
in now you know it was the same story
whether it was the pioneers who were
pioneering the West or or Rockefeller
and Carnegie because they see the vision
they make the rules and they make the
rules
until such time as those decisions begin
to impact on the rights of others and
the public interest and I think that's
where we are today and so it's time for
us the people through our elected
representatives to take back the
rulemaking and to decide what are the
rules that are in the public interest
not just the interests of the pioneers
yeah I mean of course I agree with you I
don't think it'll come as a shock to my
audience that I do but the issue that
we've had historically particularly in
the last couple of decades is that
because the desires of large
corporations and the wealthy are much
more likely to be made into what becomes
the regulatory environment what makes
the priorities of the House and Senate
and is turned into Bill's what what is
that the average person can actually do
to make sure that what's in the public's
best interest is done I mean look at
look at the net neutrality situation
right millions and millions of comments
the FCC website going down etc etc you
know the story my audience knows the
story and we've got a repeal of net
neutrality as an example so Ken Ken
what's in the public interest really be
successfully lobbied for by the public
well yes and and and the the reality
there is if you don't who will
okay so I mean so you can say all my
goodness I'm just a individual I don't
count well then you might as well turn
it over to the folks who are running the
big companies and and I wouldn't say by
the way that the net neutrality fight is
over no it's not we're in we're in court
right now challenging the the
ridiculousness of the Trump FCC's repeal
of the rules and I think I'm cautiously
optimistic about that and then the House
of Representatives passed a piece of
legislation that that reinstates the
rules so that that's very much in play
and and what we can't fall prey to is a
demand that everything has to happen
quickly this is a this is a long game
there's no question it's a long game and
one of the players that wants to have a
say in that game in terms of the
regulation is the tech companies
themselves and we've seen more and more
companies say oh we are four and we saw
Zuckerberg say it in in testimony under
oath and others I believe regulation is
a good thing and I want to work with our
elected officials to get the the
regulation in place is this something
that we should have any do you believe
that this is a good faith offer that
tech companies are making to participate
in figuring out what the regulation
should be or is it just the the fox
guarding the hen house well I don't
think it's bad faith but I think that it
is a situation of where you stand
depends on where you sit and you know
what I was chairman of the FCC people
would always come
and say oh let me tell you why what is
in my interest is in the public interest
right and and they would define things
very narrowly and what we're seeing
right now are are the tech companies
saying okay you know for instance I'm
for net neutrality but I'm for of that
definition of net neutrality being an
empty bag if you will when it comes to
the reality that many of these platforms
are both social network content
providers and they are also massive ad
brokerage platforms do you believe that
those two sides of many of these
entities need to be separated either via
antitrust or some other means well of
course that's the kind of issue that
Elizabeth Warren and others have been
have been making and I've got a lot of
respect for that I have some concern
that you know you got to love it when
your cell phone someone does not want
you to tell me what your view is on the
anti hey we've solved that problem the
but but you know you got to look at
antitrust is really three prongs yes I
mean first the first prong is is to
break up the companies the difficulty
there is it's a it's a long prong you
know it was it was ten years between the
filing of the suit to break up AT&T and
the actual breakup of a TMT and and so
that's a serious challenge and we also
have a problem that our Supreme Court
right now is hold to the Chicago School
theory that makes it very difficult to
establish arm the second prong of
antitrust enforcement is regulatory and
that's what I tried to do at the FCC and
to take competitive principles and put
them into regulation and the third prong
is this concept of openness that
you and I were just talking about and
and so I think it would be an
interesting concept if rather than just
talking about separating the social
platform from the ad sales activity we
go right to the heart of what is it that
creates the market dominance in both of
those areas and that's their data and if
we're talking about our networks being
open then we probably ought to be
talking about the services that use our
networks and in so doing capture our
personal information then making that
information also in your connectable
just like the networks are so Enzo I
mean just to be clear is that an issue
of privacy regulation is that an issue
of data ownership no I think it's an
issue of two things it goes back to the
old common law concept of the duty to
deal you can't hoard information any
more than the guy who was running the
ferry across the river to tell somebody
that he couldn't ride on the ferry and
then there's also a duty of care which
is okay I've got your information I've
got a fiduciary responsibility to you as
to how I'm going to deal with that
information and and we need to go to at
both of those and if you deal with that
then you're dealing with the core issue
that creates this monopoly power
elsewhere so in the European Union there
is now the general data protection
regulation gdpr and it does a lot of
different things one of the one of the
issues is it goes to the sort of like
the financial risk to Internet companies
for improperly sharing user data it
imposes large fines hypothetically do
you like that framework is there does it
not go far enough maybe does it go too
far no I thought gdpr was a great first
step I'm not sure it can be
a imported wholesale into the United
States because of some of our laws and
traditions but it-it-it established the
principle that there was a
responsibility to the party that was
collecting the data and but let me use
another European example that that kind
of supports they open this principle I
was just talking about and that is that
in the UK the government has required
that the nine largest banks open up or
make open access available with consumer
permission the data that they hold on
consumers so that third parties can
offer innovative new services to those
consumers that the services wouldn't be
available previously because they didn't
have access to the data and the
companies the banks were hoarding that
data and say you can only buy our
services and now they were forced to
open it up and there are two hundred
different service providers that have
sprung up saying hey I've got a
competitive way of a competitive
alternative for consumers to to consider
I think we can bring that kind of
attitude of the United States yeah I
mean that's interesting because that's a
very market ish sort of solution which
is not to say we need to make it so that
the data is not being shared in the
first place or it's not dealing so much
with what some see as the problem of
this data being a marketable commodity
but it's saying let's level the playing
field in letting that data
hypothetically at least be used to
create other things of value so it's I'm
not making a value judgment necessarily
but it's certainly a solution that says
we want more sort of free-market
possibilities rather than a consumer
protection angle is that am i
interpreting that correctly or it goes
back to the concept David of openness
and interconnected interconnection I
mean the the concept behind that
neutrality was open networks now let's
talk about how we have open
data that has been collected through the
use of those networks and when we make
that data available to spur competition
to talk a little bit about the next four
to eight years or you know the next
political cycle so to speak and what it
will happen in terms of both net
neutrality and also tack regulation that
we're talking about what are the
elements of government that are going to
most determine the path forward is it as
simple as if Trump gets reelected not
much will change at the FCC if a
Democrat wins things will change is it
elsewhere we should be looking well I
think you can make that kind of a simple
comparison I mean you you look at you
know what the Trump administration has
done thus far you know it has been to
tear everything down I mean what does
the Trump FCC done they've gone through
and systematically eliminated whatever
they can and but but there's an
interesting thing that's happening as a
result of that David and that is that
the tech companies have perhaps been too
successful they have they have may have
convinced the federal government
particularly the Trump administration to
totally leave them alone and in that
kind of a void they invite others
whether it is states like California
stepping in to pass laws on on privacy
and net neutrality 36 other states that
have stepped up to do something about
net neutrality or countries you
mentioned GDP are a minute ago and other
things that are happening in the EU and
all of a sudden the companies are waking
up and saying oh my golly you know we
don't have anybody establishing a common
set of rules and so we've got 36
different states doing things with net
neutrality golly I'd feel a lot better
if there
only one rule and so the fact that they
did everything possible to kill
meaningful net neutrality at the federal
level has opened them up at the state
level the fact that they have done
everything possible to kill meaningful
privacy regulation I mean we put the
first networked privacy requirements in
place when I was at the FCC and 67 days
after the Trump administration came into
office that the Republican Congress
repealed them and now all at the request
of the companies and now the companies
are seeing California and other states
and countries pop up and with their own
set of rules they're saying oh my golly
I can't have all these different rules
out there I've got to have one set of
rules and so it may be you know there's
a great Oscar Wilde quote he said that
he said that there are two tragedies in
life not getting what you want and
getting it and the reality here is the
tech companies just may have been so
massively successful that they have
forced themselves to embrace federal
regulation that heretofore they had
always been opposing we will of course
continue to follow it it could go a
number of different ways as you are
outlining we've been speaking with
former chairman of the FCC Tom wheeler I
will mention his book which was
published February 26th from Gutenberg
to Google the history of our future such
a pleasure having you on thanks David I
enjoyed it